well i just feel like you know since  carmelo is supposed to be old in nba  years that i feel like they were trying  to you know get him out you know  and i've always felt like he's been  great since since i've met him since  college  olympics everything he's been the same  guy  you know as far as how he plays he's  never stopped working  he can shoot the ball from anywhere on  the court  his attitude his name really speaks for  how he is he's mellow you know i'm  saying he's real chill you know he don't  get into it unless you really rally him  up but other than that when the lights  come on and it's time to go to work he's  ready at all times and i appreciate that  about him that you know one thing he's  never changed that's the best thing  about it